The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Probably the
time has begun to begin.
Welcome.
I've given a guest
lecture in this class
for a few years running now.
So I'm always happy to return.
You're working on a
good subject here.
I'm going to talk today
about experimentation
and robust design of
engineering systems.
I think you've already had
a few lectures on design
of experiments formally.
So this will build on that.
The figure that I show
on this first slide
concerns, on the right,
a method by which
one can make improvements
in robustness of the system
by adaptively experimenting
in the parameter
space of that system.
And the figure on
the left is meant
to indicate why
that approach has
worked rather quite a lot
better than people expected.
And I'll be going into
that in some detail,
and I hope that as I
go through all this,
you'll take time
to ask questions.
Because I think
that's better for you
and more interesting for me too.
So just to give you a
little bit of context,
this topic of adaptive
experimentation
and robust design is really
central to my research.
It's I think the core of it, but
I'm interested in other things
as well.
Such as we do studies
of systems generally
and the regularities that exist
in those engineered systems.
And that gives rise to data
that we can use more generally
in methodology validation.
So we can look at
different ways that people
will do engineering and try
to assess its effectiveness.
And of course,
all this is linked
in with the work on
adaptive experimentation,
because we need a way
to validate our work.
But the main topic
today will be what's
in the middle of that slide.
That's adaptive experimentation.
I think I'll start with
some history and use that
to explain the motivation.
Why is it that we're
addressing this topic?
Why are we addressing it
the way we're addressing it?
And then, I'm going to show
you the research itself
on a depth of experimentation
and robust design.
So I start with this quote
from Sir Edward John Russell.
Now, this fellow was
prominent in his day.
He was knighted.
That's why it says Sir
Edward John Russell there
under his picture.
And as late as
1926, he was still
expressing a view about
how to do experimentation.
He said that you should
seek simplicity in the way
that you conduct
your experiments,
and maybe you should ask just
a few questions at a time,
or maybe even just one
question at a time,
as you're conducting
your experiments.
And this was a prominent view
in that they generally accepted,
and you can trace it
back at least as far
as Francis Bacon
and maybe father.
And what's interesting
about this is just
at the time he's still
expressing his views about how
it is that they conducted
experiments there
at Rothamsted, he hired
another person, R.A. Fisher.
Now, I should say that this
is an interesting confluence.
You have two men, very
prominent, very successful,
coming together in the same
place at the same time.
I think the reason for that was
that this experimental station,
Rothamsted, was
addressing I think
one of the great
problems of their time
which was consistency
and efficiency
of agricultural production.
If you think about the
middle of the 19th century,
the UK and other
parts of the world
experienced terrible famines.
And so trying to do
much better in this area
was a pressing problem, probably
equivalent today to the way
we feel about energy
supply or global warming.
And now in some ways, we
take for granted food supply
at least in the developed world.
So here, we have this
confluence and R.A. Fisher
comes into the lab, and he has
a very different view about how
to do experimentation.
He analyzes this experiment,
in which we see the table
three in the middle.
This is from R.A.
Fisher's 1921 paper,
and what you see is a plot with
different levels of ammonia
being applied as
fertilizer to the fields.
And you see the influence on
the yield per acre of oats
and the decrement in each year.
Because when you
apply the fertilizer
to the same field
year after year,
its effects diminish over time.
And apparently, Fisher
was fairly discouraged
by this experiment.
When you read the paper,
you see the details,
and you see the difficulties
they experienced
in analyzing the data.
They had some pests intruding
on parts of the land,
and this made it complex to draw
inferences from the experiment.
And he was later quoted to
say the following thing which
expressed that
frustration in a way.
You have a bunch of scientists
plan an experiment based
on their knowledge
of what to do.
Later in, you call statisticians
in to analyze the data
and to get the most
precise inferences you can
and precise estimates,
and it's really too late.
The time for
statistical thinking
is before you actually
run the experiment.
That's when you can get
the greatest benefits,
and what he talked about is the
idea that the most finesse you
could apply might improve
your analysis of the data
by a few percent
one way or other.
But if you brought in the
experimenter earlier, maybe
you'd get a factor of 2 or 5
in efficiency and accuracy.
And you can see how
thoughtful Fisher was.
He seems to be struggling
hard to think there,
and I think part of it
is that machine that's
in front of him, which
is I guess what you'd
use for a computer in that day.
I guess it's some
mechanical adding device,
and I think it's nice that we
have so much better machines
now for this purpose.
And in fact, what
we find is that you
can do a lot with statistics
these days by knowing how
to work with computers right.
And in fact, a lot
of the research
results I'll show you
today, we wouldn't
be able to achieve
them with without
modern digital computers.
So Fisher begins to plan
experiments in a different way,
and this is one of the first
ones in the literature,
this figure one
from his 1926 paper
on the arrangement
of field experiments.
And if you've done
some work already
in this course on
design of experiments,
you might recognize this.
You see somewhat
indicated by darker lines
that there are eight different
subplots in this plot.
And if I focus my
attention on just
say the upper left,
what I see is--
and I think the people even
remotely can see the arrow.
Right?
You see the plot has three
different indications
in each plot.
In this case, it's
2, an M, and early.
In the next one, it's
2 and S and late.
So the 2 and the 1
indicate an amount
of a fertilizer
that's been applied.
S and M indicate the
type of the fertilizer,
and early and late
describe the time
in the season, the planting
season, when it's applied.
And we see in this
first block, we
have four of the 2's and four of
the 1's and four of the earlys
and four of the lates and so on.
And we even see that
there is a balance,
in the sense that there are
two of the two M's and two
of the two S's, so pair-wise,
there's a balance and so on.
And you may recognize
that, if I just
focus on 2 and M
and early and late,
and there are 8 of
such blocks in here,
we have every permutation
and combination
of the factors in the level.
So I would say, you could
describe this as a 2
to the 3 full
factorial experiment
within the block, which is 8.
Now, you might also say that
it's a 3 raised to the 1 and 2
raised to the 2,
because there are also
these four plots in which
there are just X's, and
no fertilizers apply.
You could call that
a control, or you
could say that this is
actually a more complex
factorial experiment,
where in one of the levels
obviates the other two.
And once you decide to
apply no fertilizer,
it doesn't matter whether
you apply type 1 or type 2
or apply early or late.
And then, to further complicate
the issue, we have eight plots,
and within those
blocks, those subplots,
we have randomization in space
of the different treatments.
And one of the things that
Fisher talks about here
is how poorly randomization
actually works sometimes.
So if I look down in this
plot, it's on the lower right.
This plot is randomized
in spatial distribution
of the treatments, but you see
that all of the left-hand plots
are early, and all of the
right-hand plots are late.
So sometimes, randomization
gives you such problems,
and in fact, these
days, often people
will not use randomization
and instead use
something like a
Latin hypercube design
rather than randomization.
But this was one of the
early experiments that
had been considered
in a factorial design,
and I think it's interesting
that Fischer decided to call it
a complex experiment.
It's as if he was
trying to emphasize
as strongly as possible
his difference of opinion
with Russell, his boss, who
had said that you should seek
simplicity in your experiments.
And he was saying, no, I'm
going to do the exact opposite.
I'm going to make my
experiment as complex as I can.
And here's the motivation
for doing that,
and this I think is one of
the great results of Fisher,
is that he was able to
demonstrate the specific value
that you could attain by
making the experiment complex.
And what we have here on
the upper right of the slide
is a cuboidal
representation of the 2
to the 3 factorial design.
This may not be the first time
you've seen it in this course,
but you have the three different
levels labeled as A, B, and C,
and the factors
labeled as A, B, and C
and the levels indicate
as pluses and minuses.
And the way that you would
estimate the effect of A
is by looking at the
observations, where
A is at level plus, taking
the average of those four.
And then taking all of
the observations where
A is at minus, taking
the average of those four
and looking at that difference,
and that's the equation here.
The effect if A is defined
as this equation which
just implements what I
just described in words.
And then what Fisher
is able to show
is that the standard deviation
of the effect estimate
has the following form.
It is a function of
the experimental error,
if I model the random variations
in the observation due to,
let's say, soil pH
or the pests that I
spoke of earlier or uneven
distribution of water
on the fields.
If all of those nuisance
factors that I didn't control
influence my yields at
the various locations,
and those contribute
to sigma sub-epsilon,
those will be
reflected in sigma sub
A, my estimate of
the influence of,
say, applying the
fertilizer early or late.
But they are reflected in
sigma sub A substantially
less if I use this
factorial design rather than
a single-factor experiment.
And he could show that for
the case of the 2 to the 3
full factorial, the improvement
in efficiency is a factor of 2.
So it's a large benefit as
compared to the benefits
that you could derive by a
different kind of analysis
of the data.
The planning of the data
made a huge difference.
But the problem
is that, if you're
using a full
factorial experiment,
you see 2 to the
3 or 2 to the k,
the scaling with the number
of factors is terrible.
Right?
And so you find that you can't
run such experiments with more
than, say, seven factors.
That's about the largest that
I've seen published in tables,
so that we can analyze
them, because then you
have 128 data
elements to include
in the appendix of your paper.
So they're rarely run with
more than seven factors.
And yet in an experimentation,
especially in engineering,
we often have many
more than seven
factors we're concerned with.
It's not at all uncommon.
And so almost
immediately, Fisher
begins to consider the
possibility of some means
to reduce the size
of the experiment,
even as the number
of factors goes up.
And this is the way he
describes thinking about that.
You deliberately
sacrifice possibility
of obtaining information
on some points.
So you decide there
are certain things
that you would be able to
estimate in the full factorial,
but you just decide
ahead of time
that they're not worth
investigating, that maybe
they're unlikely a priori.
And so you design the experiment
so that you can't possibly
obtain information about them.
But actually, it's a
little worse than that,
I'm going to show you later.
Not only do you not have
a possibility of obtaining
information about those
points, those specific points,
if they were to be
consequential in the end,
would actually interfere
considerably with your ability
to make inferences.
And so this is the simplest
fractional factorial
I can show you.
Again, we have the cuboidal
representation, and what we do
is just to make observations
at half of the vertices.
So I indicate those by the
black plus's, and these four
are selected in a specific
arrangement to give us the 2
to the 3 minus 1 half
fraction with resolution 3.
I'll describe what resolution
3 means in a second.
One of the things
that's interesting
about the experiment in my mind
is its projective properties.
So we see that, if we
collapse factor A--
that is, if we imagine that
there is a flashlight or such,
a source of light
off to the right,
and we get a projection
of the matrix of the cube,
and now we just get a square.
We'd see that if
factor A is collapsed,
we would have a full factorial
experiment in B and C.
Have you studied these
projective properties
in the other parts
of the course?
OK.
And so it goes in the
other dimensions as well.
And so in my mind,
what's interesting about
this is that in a way the
design of the experiment
allows you to account for a
particular kind of uncertainty.
If you have a long
list of factors,
and you're not sure
which ones are going
to be the important
ones, you know
that some few will turn
out to be important,
but you're not sure which ones.
You can arrange it
so that you will
have done a full factorial
in the few important factors
without knowing exactly
which ones you need to do
a full factorial experiment in.
And that's what the projective
properties allow you to do.
But all this comes at a cost,
and the cost is more easily
described by looking at a
larger fractional factorial
experiment.
This is the 2 to the 7 minus
4 design, and what we see here
is that, if we have 7 factors,
and we want to stuff them
into a small experiment
with just say 8 trials,
then what we can do is put
them in this arrangement.
And the risk is that
if, for example,
there is a two-factor
interaction between F and G,
then that will emerge
in this pattern.
That in the first four
experiments, F and G
are all at the same level,
either plus and plus
or minus and minus.
And in the last
four experiments,
they're all at different
levels, such as minus and plus
or plus and minus.
And so if the two
are interacting
in some important
way, the effect
will emerge in
such a way that it
is coming into being
exactly when A is at minus,
or A is at plus, and
so you will confound
the two in your analysis.
And if you think that
an effect of A itself
is more likely than a two-factor
interaction of F and G,
you're likely to make a mistake,
to assign that effect to A,
whereas, it actually
occurred due to F and G.
That's the risk that you have
to take to make a relatively
small experiment
that's investigating
a lot of potential factors.
So these are the trade-offs we
make in experimental design.
Now, one of the reasons
that this whole topic is
important to engineers
is that we're
concerned with robustness,
robust parameter design.
And what I'm showing
here is the cover of one
of the I think probably
the best modern compilation
of this topic on experimental
design and its application
to engineering
systems, in particular
for the pursuit of robustness.
And Jeff Wu and
Michael [? Hamouda ?]
define robust
parameter design here
as a set of statistical
and engineering methodology
to reduce performance
variation by choosing
settings of control factors to
make the system less sensitive.
So you're trying to find
things that you can control
in an experiment in
the design and to use
those to make performance
less sensitive to things
that you don't control.
Can you think of examples
relevant to your work
of something you
might make robust?
Or even simpler, just
of a noise factor
you might be concerned
with, something
that influences a system.
Well, we'll have
more examples later,
and in fact, I believe
that in the past,
this course has had some
projects associated with it.
And in some cases, people
want to do robust parameter
design and projects.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
So you might be doing injection
molding or a process like that,
and you could control
temperature and humidity
but at some great cost I guess.
So you might choose to
allow those things to vary
to some degree.
And if they influence say
the geometry of your parts,
resulting parts, too
much, you would probably
be producing less
value to your customer.
Probably the function
of your articles
themselves might be
degraded by that,
and so you might like to
choose process parameters,
such as pressures and
compositions of your plastic
and so on, so that that
effect is minimized.
So you decide not to
control the humidity
but just to be
insensitive to it.
There.
Good.
So on the cover
of this textbook,
you see actually
something called
a crossarray it's hard to
pick out, unless you go
and zoom in on
your own computer.
But you see capital
A, B, and C over here,
and those represent
control factors,
such as pressure and
speed of the extruder
and the composition of the
plastic, things that you
might control nominally.
And then there's
little a and b, those
are temperature and
humidity and things
you might decide you're not
going to control so much.
And you see that fractional
factorial designs
or factorial designs
are being used
in each of these arrangements
shown to the left and above,
and then the crossing, the
product of those two designs,
is indicated in the middle.
And here, Wu actually begins
to hint and foreshadow
about the idea of what he
calls a combiner experiment.
So he shows some of these being
white and some being dark,
and he's suggesting that as
a way to address the rather
large size of this experiment.
So it turns out that
the first person
to pioneer this idea of bringing
in fractional factorial designs
into the plant and
using them explicitly
for the purpose of robustness
improvements, person
who seems to most often
get credit for this,
is Taguchi, in Japan.
So he begins to do work, in
Japan, after World War II, when
their manufacturing
base is in disarray,
and their economy is
in not good shape,
and their reputation
for manufacturing
is very poor at that time too.
So if you bought a product, and
it said made in Japan on it,
people would actually
imagine that that meant
it was of rather poor quality.
And of course, our impression
is totally the opposite now,
and it's interesting to
consider how that happened.
It was a lot of
different things.
But maybe one of the
things that brought
that change about
in our perception
of Japanese manufacture was
some of this methodology.
And Taguchi
correctly pointed out
that robustness
could be attained,
and it could be attained
through experimentation.
And he suggested that you might,
for example, run an experiment
like this, an orthogonal array
or factorial design and control
factors crossed
with noise factors.
And in this case, you take your
8-run array of control factors,
cross it with your 4-run
array of noise factors,
and you would have
a 32-run crossarray.
And so you see with
this cross symbol,
the implication is that
the size of the experiment
scales at least like the
product of the number
of control factors plus
1 and the number of noise
factors plus 1.
Which when you begin
to consider lots
of control of noise factors,
it gets awfully burdensome.
So people are looking for ways
to do it more efficiently,
and that leads to the cover of
this textbook, the idea of just
doing half of them, so that
you're actually not running
exactly the same
noise conditions
at every setting of
the control factors.
And what we've done
in our methodology
validation work actually is to
show in a recent publication
in the Journal of
Quality Technology
that this procedure,
although theoretically looks
promising in many specific
cases, it's failing.
And yet, if I look at
industry practice today,
I think the methods
of Taguchi and also
the refinements
proposed more recently
on the basis of
statistical theory
are finding their way
into industry practice
and are really quite
solidly entrenched.
So some of you may have had some
experience with these Six Sigma
programs by now.
Maybe some of you are in General
Electric, maybe some Motorola,
and I guess many other companies
by now have such programs.
And a big part of such programs
is that entering engineers
will take some coursework,
even if they didn't get it
in their undergraduate degrees.
The company feels people
broadly need this,
and so they get some coursework,
and then they do projects.
Right?
And they demonstrate
that they can
do some of this kind of
work for the company,
and at Ford, at
least the last time
I checked, their design
process encoded just this sort
of thing, and they have
their multi-step process
for attaining reliability
and robustness.
And in step four, I dig in
and look at the details,
and the engineers
are asked to select
appropriate orthogonal arrays.
So the idea is that
maybe they have
some choices about what
size of orthogonal array,
number of levels,
the crossed array
versus the combined array,
such as Wu talked about.
But a departure from
orthogonal arrays
itself is not really being
considered anymore in industry,
and so this has become
very much entrenched.
And in fact, in some
of the textbooks,
you see an even more extreme
statement of the point.
In this text, they argue that
the idea that Edward John
Russell expressed on that
earlier slide, that simplicity
should be valued, and that
single-factor experiments
are often advisable, that
has seen its final demise.
So that's the opinion voiced
in this particular textbook.
But we wanted to question
this a little bit.
We wondered if sometimes there
isn't a role for the simpler
experiments still,
and this decision
to spend some time
looking into this
came out of some
observations in industry.
And I thought in some ways
now, it seems a shock to me
that our initial thoughts
along these lines
came out of the farm again.
So that all these ideas
of orthogonal arrays
and so on came from
agriculture in the first place,
and now our wanting to question
them came off of the farm,
because we were working
with a manufacturer
of agricultural equipment.
And it seems to me actually
that farm equipment
is one of the most significant
robustness challenges
in the world.
Because what you have in
a tractor or a windrower
or a combine is
really a factory.
It needs to process
something, sometimes in not
a very simple way.
Sometimes, it needs to take
a piece of cotton off a plant
and then strip away
some part of it.
It's not a simple thing.
And yet here it is, and
it's out in the weather.
It's out in a field.
Whatever conditions prevail,
it has to deal with.
So it's a very difficult
reliability challenge.
And this particular company
had relatively recently
brought in a lot of
robust design methodology,
and they were looking forward to
the benefits that would accrue.
And they got exactly
the opposite,
that this most recent
launch of a new tractor
was one of the worst
they'd ever had,
and it was causing
them real problems.
Their customers were
quite angry with them.
And so we wanted
to look into that,
and we decided to, in
effect, do an audit,
look at their design
process for this tractor.
What had happened?
Were there some mistakes in
choices of design or priority
or management, whatever?
So one of the things
that we asked for
is an accounting of all
the different robust design
experiments they had
done, and they gave us
a list of experiments
they planned.
It was a long list, and
then we said, well, yeah,
but we need more detail in this.
Show us the written reports
from all these experiments.
Show us the data.
Show us the decisions
made basis of the data.
And they gave us a much
smaller list of reports,
and we said, OK, you had
30, and now we have 5.
What about the other 25?
And they said, well,
those were never finished,
and that was interesting to us.
Why is it that the
majority weren't finished?
And we began to ask questions
of the individuals involved,
and they always have
pretty good reasons.
In some cases, they would say
that a piece of test equipment
had broken down at some
point along the way
and was going to take a certain
amount of time to repair,
so we had to move forward
with a partial data set.
In fact, a large fraction of
the experiments aren't finished,
and this prompted us to
wonder, what would you
do if you knew this
from the outset?
Let's say that you
put a 60% probability
on canceling any
individual experiment you
might run somewhere at a
state of partial completion.
Let's say that were
the case, but you
didn't know which
60% we're going
to be canceled, because you
probably don't know that.
What would you do?
Well, we thought, perhaps,
you would do a one
at a time experiment,
because then at least,
no matter what you did,
you would have stopped,
and the data would be
relatively simple to analyze,
such as what Russell
talked about.
And we found that actually
some of the most prominent
statisticians in
the past always felt
that there was a role for one
factor at a time experiments.
So for example, you may have
heard of Milton Friedman
in a different context.
What do you know him for?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah.
Nobel Prize in
economics, market view
of economics and
Leonard Savage who
had written an excellent text
on foundations of statistics.
They found that an efficient
design for the present
purposes-- that was
for maximization--
ought to adjust experimental
program at each stage in light
of the prior stages, and
actually, what they described
was a one factor at
a time experiment.
And then Cuthbert
Daniel talked about
a more social or psychological
value of simpler experiments,
just reemphasizing the
points that Edward John
Russell had made.
That somehow you feel that you
can react to data more rapidly
or learn something
from each rung.
And he talked
about some criteria
by which you might
make that choice,
that for example, he
had a demarcation.
Maybe it's OK to do it,
as long as the effects
are at least three or four
times the average random error
per trail.
So he had, based
on his experience,
come up with a demarcation--
effects three or four
times random error.
And we wanted to understand
whether that demarcation was
about right, so
we began to study
an adaptive variant of one
factor of time experimentation.
And in the beginning, we
were interested primarily
in knowing, if you were to do
this adaptive experimentation,
what level of probability
of canceling the experiments
would make this style look good?
And the funny thing about it
is we started with some maybe
50% probability of canceling,
and we looked at the two
experimentation styles, adaptive
and factorial, and on the cases
we were looking at,
adaptive looked better.
And so we dialed
down the probability
of canceling the 10%, and
they still looked better.
And we dialed it down to 0%, and
the adaptive experiment still
looked better.
And we thought, well, now we
know we've made a mistake,
because we saw it
in the textbooks
that this kind of
experimentation
has seen its final demise.
So either we made a mistake in
the way we set up the study,
or we chose a strange
case to start with.
We were perplexed.
So we did eventually a
big empirical evaluation,
and we took 66 different systems
of a broad range of kinds--
chemical systems, mechanical
systems, electrical systems,
and we made our comparison in
this case without canceling.
Now, we were interested
in that issue.
Imagine that you're going to
do this adaptive, one factor
at a time experimentation.
You're going to compare that
with a fractional factorial
experiment and see which
one does better on average.
And this is what we
found is that, as
long as experimental
error was about 25%
of combined factor effect, or if
interactions were large enough,
then you'd prefer the
adaptive experiments.
And so here is that same
result shown in a tabular form.
So we have on the
column headings
the degree of experimental
error expressed
as a fraction of the factor
effects, and we have on the row
headings the strength
of interactions--
mild, moderate,
strong, dominant.
Strong interactions would
indicate that the interactions
are counting for
more than a quarter
of effects in the system,
quite a big fraction,
and moderate is
maybe 10% to 25%.
And the gray boxes indicate
that the adaptive one factor
at a time experiments
were giving
at least as good
or better results
than the fractional factorial,
and so you might prefer them,
especially given
their flexibility.
And so we were surprised
at how much of that
territory turns out to be gray,
and that was the main result
we wanted to get
across in this paper.
And we thought, a strength
of the experimental error
as large as 0.4 looks like
a lot of experimental error
to us, to engineers.
When you see a dependence,
such as this blue line
here, on the figure
and the scatter
being indicated
by the red, that's
about typical of the strength
of experimental error at 0.4
that we expressed,
and to us that
looks like a pretty
noisy experiment.
And so we thought it
was interesting how
much of the time you might
recommend these experiments.
So we wanted to understand
how this could be,
since it seems so
counterintuitive to us.
And so we delved into it
a little more in terms
of the mathematics, and we
tried to develop a theory that
would account for this.
So we started to write
a model of the procedure
of adaptive one factor at
a time experimentation,
and so there's just a
little notation here.
You imagine that you make
an initial observation.
Some of the symbols are
coming up a little wrong.
This is an x with a tilde over
it is an initial starting point
level for factor one.
And x2 with a tilde is
the same, and that k
should be an
ellipsis, three dots.
And then you change
one of the factors.
You toggle it, change it to the
opposite of the starting value,
and that's your
first observation.
And then you make a
decision about the level
of the first factor based on
the sign of the differences
in the observations.
So if the improvement seems to
obtain, we adopt the change,
and then we go through
that for every one
of the different factors,
putting stars on our x's, and
we continue.
And what we're
interested in knowing
is how does the expected
value of improvement
behave as a function of a
number of parameters in a model?
And the parameters we
put in our model are few.
We talked about the size
of main effects in general,
the size of interactions, and
the size of experimental error,
because our empirical
investigation
had shown that those were
interesting to look at.
And here, we show we wanted to
normalize those with respect
to the maximum, the
best that you could do,
so that our results could
be easily interpreted.
And another concept we
introduced in this paper,
we felt we needed to
explain the results,
was the idea of
exploiting an effect.
So we had to introduce
the idea that, when
you do an experiment, if your
system has a number of effects
in it, main effects
or interactions,
they can either be
exploited or not,
and we'll say that they're
exploited, just in case.
For example, if you're trying
to get a higher response out
of the system-- let's say yield
out of a field [? of oats, ?]
or quality of a
manufactured article.
Then, you exploit an
effect, if the coefficient
in the model times the
level of the factor
is such that it's contributing
positively to your outcome.
And you exploit an
interaction in the system
basically under
the same condition.
That if the two
factors involved are
such that you're gaining
benefit from the coefficient
in the model, either
increasing or decreasing
the response depending
on what you prefer,
we call that one exploited.
So we wanted to understand
the probabilities
and conditional
probabilities associated
with this adaptive experiment.
So we begin to do the theorem
proving based on our model,
and we find, first
of all, that if you
change just the first
factor and compute
the expected value
of improvement,
you have two different
kinds of contributions--
1 due to a main effect and n
minus 1 due to interactions.
So you change factor
1, and this figure here
is meant to indicate the
condition with n equals 7.
You've got 7 factors
you're interested in,
and this stack of squares
indicates the contribution
of main effects.
And none of these other factors
are contributing anything,
but now the main effect
of the first factor
is contributing quite a bit
on average, after you've
done the adaptation.
And all of the 6 potential
two-factor interactions
are on average contributing
a little to improvement,
because it may be
that in some cases
there'll be a large
two-factor interaction.
And you'll see it when
you toggle the factors,
and you'll go chase
that, and so on average,
it's contributing something.
And we could write
closed form expressions
for the contribution,
and the contribution
due to main effects
is larger when
the main effects are larger.
It tends to be smaller
when interactions are large
and when error is large.
The contributions
to the interactions
are large when interactions
are large in the model.
And interesting to us, if you
write out the expected value,
normalize by the maximum,
so that the improvements are
on this scale either 0 or
1 or scaled in between.
The contribution you
would get in the case
that experimental error
is low-- so here I
put experimental error
at 10% of a main effect.
The contribution you get after
running one 1 of 7 factors
is actually about 1/7.
So you get 1/7 of the
way toward the maximum
by changing 1/7 of the factors.
That's a good start.
And the influence of error is--
it's there.
As you go to error being
as large as main effects,
it drops a little,
and of course,
if you make the
error really huge,
it drops quite substantially.
But that's a hard test
to pass, but we're just
trying to understand
what the influences are.
OK.
Now, let's talk about
probability of exploiting
the first main effect.
Just when interactions
are small,
the probability of getting
the benefit of the main effect
is large.
Then, as interactions
increase, it's
less likely that you'll get
the benefit of the main effect.
Now, it becomes interesting
at the second step.
Now, you've toggled
two factors, and then
what we think about it is this.
Now, you've got the benefit
of two main effects,
and you get first n minus 1
and then n minus 2 interactions
potentially contributing.
And at this point, I
hash it in, because this
is the first interaction which
you've actually locked in.
In the sense that
any further changes
you make through the
experimentation process
will not reverse whatever
benefits you got.
Because you've already
changed one and changed two,
and you've made your
decision about that.
And now, we see that
there's a contribution
due to the interaction,
and the interaction
is the same functional
form as I showed before.
That the contribution is large
when the interaction is large.
Again, we see that the expected
value has gone from about 1/7
to about 2/7.
So we're continuing to step
forward at a good rate,
and we want to understand why.
Well, OK.
We see the probability of
exploiting the interaction.
We can write it's
closed form expression.
It's strictly better than 50-50.
So it's in any case
better than random,
and it goes up with
interaction strength.
Now, the interesting
thing about it,
it's never very high,
because actually,
any particular
interaction is competing
with n choose 2
other interactions
or n choose 2 minus 1.
And so any particular
one is unlikely to be
exploited by this procedure, and
so maybe we get a 60% chance.
But if you condition that
probability, if you say,
well, let's say that this
particular interaction
that we just locked
in is somehow
the largest one in the system.
Let's say that that happened.
We conditioned the probability,
we get a new expression,
and the probability
could be as high as 80%.
The reason that's
interesting to us
is that we know that the
adaptive one-factor experiments
are just not capable of allowing
you to estimate interactions.
You take a factor, you change
it, you look at the influence,
and what you're seeing
is a combination
of the main effective
the factor and a bunch
of conditional
contributions due to a bunch
of different interactions.
And so you can't sort
out which one is which.
You would need more
experiments to do that.
Nevertheless, if there's
a big effect there,
there's a good chance you'll
get benefit from it, when you
do this adaptive experiment.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's an interesting question,
and this is something
that we were concerned with.
All the results I'm
showing you today
assume that you've randomized
the ordering of the factors
and that you've randomized
the starting point.
And so far, what our
investigations show
is that the ordering
of the factors
doesn't matter much but
the starting points do.
So I would say, whether or
not you order the factors
from the most important one
to the next to the next,
it's a minor
improvement, not big.
But if you select a very
promising starting point, that
is go with something that
is likely to be very robust,
high performance, that
makes a big difference.
And it wasn't obvious
to us at the start.
I thought probably
what you said was true.
It turned out to be
the other way around.
So the dynamics of this
process of experimentation
are such that it turns out
the probability of exploiting
interactions as
you go gets higher
and higher throughout the
course of the experiment.
So it's true that, if you knew
where the interactions lie,
you'd like to toggle
them for the last time
as late as possible.
But I guess I don't really
believe that people would
be able to identify which
two interactions are going
to be involved, so I ruled that
out and didn't study it much.
But the point is that, even if
you didn't know where they lie,
the benefits continue to
accrue almost linearly.
Even though you're
exploiting fewer and fewer
new interactions
as you go, you see
the white ones left to benefit
are diminishing over time.
But because their likelihood
of coming in your favor
is increasing, you go
up almost linearly,
and you get almost
to the end, 80%.
You can almost to one,
well, pretty close,
And what's interesting
to us about this
is take the case of 7 factors.
The adaptive one factor at
a time, assuming two levels,
that takes 8 experiments.
The full factorial takes 128.
So you've looked at a very small
fraction of the overall space,
and you've gotten 80% of
the way toward the best
possible outcome in the space.
That to us is interesting.
And then if I want to compare
the use of resolution 3 designs
and adaptive designs, we
have expressions for each.
And then to make the
comparison straight,
one against the other,
we do the following.
Just hold them up against
one another, look at--
we see the experimental error
is plotted parametrically.
So let's look at just
the crossing point when
experimental error is about
the size of main effect.
They cross at the point
where interactions are
about a quarter of main effect.
The reason we think
that one is interesting
is that I alluded
to earlier the idea
that we are doing these studies,
big studies of complex systems
and regularities.
And one of the things we
found is that interactions
being about a quarter of the
size of main effects, that's
pretty typical.
That's a typical amount.
So if you go into a factory,
and you get your engineers
to list a number of factors
they're interested in studying.
And then you run
a big experiment
and study some of
the interactions too,
you will generally find they're
about a quarter of the size
of the main effects.
It's just a reasonably
reliable regularity,
and so we think that's typical.
And the way I would
interpret the graph
is that, if your
system is pretty
typical in this regard,
strength of interactions,
you should be doing the adaptive
experiments whenever error
is less than main effects.
So Cuthbert Daniels
criterion for demarcation
was error should
be about a third
or a quarter of main effects,
and we're saying now,
it's actually more like the
size of main effects, not
a third or a quarter.
That's assuming, importantly,
that your main goal is just
getting improvement, knowing
exactly where they came from
or estimating
effects accurately.
Now, our primary reason
for going into all this
in the first place was to deal
with robust design in the end.
And so we attempted lots of
different ways of combining
the noise factors with
the control factors,
and so far, the simplest thing
turned out to be the best.
And that is what you see here
in this cuboidal representation
are controllable
factors A, B, and C
and our noise factors,
little a, b, and c,
are being crossed in effect.
We take the adaptive procedure.
We run a factorial
design in the noise.
Then, change one of the
control factors, just one,
and run again the
exact same design.
And then what we do is we select
our level, in this case of A,
on the basis of our preference
for this set of observations
versus this set.
If we like this set because,
for example, it has lower
variation, then we select it.
We select A as
positive, and then
we just continue to wind
our way through the space,
reversing changes
that we don't like
and adopting ones that we do.
And we study this, this says--
it actually appeared
in ASME journal.
I've got to change that.
So we began to
validate this approach
by applying it to a number
of different systems.
One that might be of interest
to you is sheet metal spinning.
So in this process, you
go into your factory,
you take sheet metal
articles, and you turn them
into manufactured goods,
surfaces of revolution,
cups, and bells and
whatever you need.
By taking the circular
blank, pressing it up
against a mandrel repetitively,
until you get the deformation
that you want.
And you might be interested,
for example, in consistency
of the geometry,
and you might be
interested in how a number
of different parameters
affect that consistency
of the geometry.
Such as what material you
chose, the shape of the mandrel,
the shape of the path which
you use, the number of times
and the force you apply.
And this was studied
by a group in Germany,
and we used their
results to simulate
the process of running
these adaptive experiments
and running an
alternative across the ray
design on these systems.
And we found that the
Taguchi-style crossed
array made indeed improvements
in signal to noise
ratio of the system, but
our adaptive procedures
were doing a little
better, until you
got to some crossing point,
an experimental error up here
of 2 millimeters squared
of this quality measure.
And this is where we found
another result, the one that I
alluded to earlier.
That if you gave the engineers
the benefit of the doubt
and suggested that they didn't
choose their starting points
at random, but instead choose
informed starting points.
And let me define
what I mean by that.
Let's say, you have
a number of factors.
They're all at two levels,
a random starting point
is just flipping coins.
You choose each one.
But let's say that
somehow the engineers
are able to do better than
50% odds of getting the best
setting for each
factor, but instead have
75% chance of defining the
superior level of each factor.
In that case in
the end they would
get this result,
substantially higher
than either of the
other two alternatives,
and they'll never cross, no
matter how much error there is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is it saying
the smaller the better
on the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So smaller the better is
the parameter of interest
was meant to be
smaller is better.
But then, when you compute
a signal to noise ratio,
larger it's better.
So the underlying
parameter, called
A20 in this case,
smaller was better.
But in Taguchi's
methodology, you then
take that parameter
and its variation
and transform it to get
a signal to noise ratio,
and with signal to noise
ratio, larger is always better.
So I appreciate why
that's confusing.
This one I included
in the paper,
and I include it for you.
Because in some cases,
you'll feel skeptical
about these results,
because they still
are pretty counterintuitive.
And you might need to
demonstrate them to yourself,
and the paper airplane
allows you to do that.
So Steve [? Effinger ?]
came up with this template
for demonstrating
some of the methods
here in robust design and
design of experiments.
And the template
allows you to fold
a variety of different paper
airplanes, in this case,
it's 3 to the 4th, or 81
different paper airplanes.
And we ran an
experiment in which
we had created different noise
conditions for the flights,
and you could
replicate our results.
Actually throw these airplanes
and do it adaptively one factor
at a time, and I think
you'll find the same results
as we did.
That if you do the
L9 Taguchi array,
or else that's a
[? Plackit-Berman ?] design
by another name, cross with a
2 to the 3 minus 1 noise array,
you get these kind of
improvements in signal to noise
ratio.
But if you run it adaptively
with random starting points,
you'll get better results.
And if you use an
informed starting point,
such as looking at a plane
that has about the right aspect
ratio, and maybe
you know right ahead
that folding up the
little winglets out here
is probably better
for lateral stability.
If you make such judgments,
you'll get even better results,
and so that's what the paper
airplane study tells us.
So we did four such
studies, and here's a point
that I find interesting.
OK?
First of all, if you're to lower
error states, what you find
is that, on average, the
random approach, starting
at random starting
points, works better
than the fractional factorial.
Informed starting points
are better than that.
If you raise the error high
enough, things turn around,
and the factorial design
is a little better
than the adaptive approach,
unless we use the informed
starting point.
But what I think is
further interesting
is that if you look
at the interquartile--
if you look at the range
of results across cases,
the adaptive procedure
even at high error,
to me that's a preferable
range, 51 to 87 versus 36 to 88.
I think you actually
take less risk
from case to case with
the adaptive method.
The factorial
design is optimally
suited to minimize the
influence of experimental error
on your outcomes.
But some of the uncertainties
you face in experimentation
aren't that kind.
They're not experimental error.
They're actually uncertainties
about where the interactions
lie, and in fact,
fractional factorial designs
are among the most
sensitive designs
to that particular uncertainty.
Because when you
make this confounding
between main effects
and interactions,
it's actually very
harmful to your outcomes.
So those are the
principle results
that I meant to show you today.
There are a couple
other things that
have emerged more recently
that I can talk about.
For example,
recently, we've been
interested in the idea
of producing ensembles.
Now, here, the
situation is that you
might find that you have an
adequate budget to run a larger
fractional factorial design.
Let's say instead of
a 2 to the 7 minus 4,
you actually have a budget to
run a much larger experiment, 2
to the 7 minus 2.
So the counterargument
from some folks in industry
was that they rarely ran
resolution 3 designs.
They thought that that
was too big a risk anyway.
They were tending to run
larger experiments, such as 2
to the 7 minus 2
higher resolution
fractional factorial designs.
And they said, so
because of that,
I don't think we should
do the adaptive OFAT,
and we were interested in
that condition, that issue.
It turns out that, if you take
the same budget that it takes
to do the 2 to the
7 minus 2, you would
be able to run four OFATs.
Now, if you do
that, if you choose
four different starting points
and four different orderings
of the factors and run
four OFATs, and then
take those results and
make an ensemble of them.
And for example, a
simple thing you could do
is just pick the
best of the four.
Again, the ensemble would
produce a better result
than the fractional
factorial design.
And then the
interesting thing we
find about it is, remember
before, when you increase
experimental error, you
expect the OFAT to eventually
degrade in performance
and to cross
with the fractional factorial.
So now, the issue is how
much experimental error
can I endure before the
adaptive experiment is
no longer recommended?
With the ensemble method, it's
actually the opposite way.
As you increase
experimental error,
eventually, the distance
between the ensemble
and the fractional
factorial increases.
So the ensemble method by
itself is providing a robustness
to experimental error.
And so we've been
able to address
another one of the counterpoints
to the adaptive experimentation
idea.
That in those cases where
experimental budgets are
higher, you might still
want to run these.
The other benefit
of the ensembles
we've been able to
show in another paper.
I didn't put some
slides in, but I
want to tell you a
little bit about it.
Unless you have a question.
Maybe I'll take your question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So what are some
practical issues
that you face influencing
one factor at a time.
For example, I can
think in my mind,
say you can't do the
measurement immediately
after each experiment.
Right?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: In that case,
you would probably still
have to go to some
fractional factorial design.
Are there other issues
that-- like practically,
because this is incredible.
It seems like it could save a
lot of people a lot of time.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you make a good point.
For example, we
know in agriculture,
you want to run 64 different
treatment conditions,
and it takes a season
to get your results.
So you want to run
them in parallel.
It's important to
run experiments
in parallel in agriculture,
and in agricultural equipment,
it's exactly the opposite.
So what happens is
you're trying to develop
the next generation of tractor.
And what they do is they take
the last generation of tractor
that they built, and they use
that as what they call a mule.
In the automotive industry,
they use the same term.
You're making the next Taurus.
You take the 2007
Taurus, and you
start using it, putting
additions on it--
new fuel injection, new
valve timing, and so on.
You use that as a mule, and
when you're using articles
like that in that style, and you
have a limited number of them,
actually, your experiments
are necessarily sequential.
Whereas, in agriculture,
they're necessarily parallel.
So I actually agree
with you, when
you're in an
engineering scenario,
and your experiments are
necessarily parallel.
It sometimes happens,
in say lithography.
You're going to etch it.
You're going to have to
etch all these things
all at the same time in a batch.
Yeah.
That's a reason to
do it the other way,
but I think more often than
not, we're doing our experiments
necessarily
sequentially, or maybe
it's OK to do it sequentially.
Another factor, since you
asked, is the possibility
of time trends, and
indeed, when you
do adaptive experimentation,
you are necessarily making
restrictions on randomization.
Right?
So let's say that you're
measuring apparatus
is drifting over time.
Let's say it's
drifting toward making
all your results look worse.
That would give you
somewhat of a bias
toward your starting points,
as opposed to all the leader
changes.
As best we can tell, actually,
the adaptive procedure
is not so hypersensitive
to those time trends.
They reflect themselves
to some degree
as if they were additional
experimental error.
But if you randomize the
starting points anyway
and the order of
factors, I don't
think it's worse than
experimental error.
Because you're not interested
in factor effects in the end
anyway.
This is probably the biggest
concern I think with the method
as I'm describing it.
The biggest issue is you're
making an explicit trade-off
to say, what I'm interested in
doing in this case is getting
some improvement.
And I'm willing to make a change
in my experimental procedure
that will give me somewhat
less knowledge about why
I got the improvement.
Now, if you're at
Ford, and you've
got three months
to product release,
and you need to meet
your emission standards.
The goal is to reduce carbon
monoxide in those three months,
and you think the
learning that you're
going to gain about
this particular engine
and its configuration
is not likely to be
reusable on the next one.
Then, in that case, I think the
adaptive method makes sense.
If instead you think the
primary value of your experiment
is archival.
Right?
You're doing the
experiment, you're
going to take the
results, you're
going to make them available
to all Ford engineers,
and you're going to
benefit on the next model
and the next model.
Then, yeah, you probably ought
to arrange the experiments,
so that you get the
highest precision
of effect estimation, the
highest validity of inference.
That's factorial
design of experiments.
But we had an interesting
learning along the way
and that is to do
our big meta studies,
where we're trying to decide
how big are interactions?
When do they occur?
We went into Ford's databases.
They had run lots of
experiments in the past,
and they had them in
some company database.
And we were drawing these
data sets out to put them
into one of our studies.
And very frequently, we'd
go through the table,
and there was some
ambiguity in our minds.
Maybe there was a plus in the
experimental matrix, where
we thought there should
have been a minus,
or there's some question.
And in those cases, we would
go track the person down
and ask them what they meant.
And in almost every case,
that person would say,
huh, you're the first
person who ever called me
about my experiment.
They'd put it in the database,
and no one was using it.
We were the first ones
to go back in and use it.
So we are not so sanguine
about the prospects of people
reusing experimental
data, at least so far
as industrial, day-to-day
experimentation is concerned.
Most often, those experiments
serve their purposes
at the time, and then they're
gone, for practical purposes.
AUDIENCE: On that note, I was
working for a startup company,
and we would use a facility
that we knew other larger
corporations would use.
And we had a much
smaller budget,
and I wouldn't to say that
my mind [INAUDIBLE] we
didn't go in with a
full factorial design,
because but we couldn't, but
we had certain objectives,
certain targets.
And so we go in and say, all
right, look at the results
vary and then change
the parameters.
I think your method has to
be more educated than that,
but it almost seems like
it's a similar mentality.
PROFESSOR: It is.
Yeah, and in fact, I never
formally tried to study this.
But if you back off a little
bit from our structure
and apply some
different structure, one
that suits your
circumstances, it's
probably still pretty good.
It might even be better.
The bigger point is that you're
doing adaptation as you go.
And I have been asked the
same question, in fact,
Jeff Wu asked me at the last
time I presented a conference.
He asked, how much of this
result is due to adaptation,
and how much is due to the
one factor at a time part?
Because this is both.
Right?
And it's a hard
question to answer.
My sense is it's
mostly adaptation.
On the other hand, one factor
at a time in some sense
optimizes adaptation.
You can be adaptive all the
time with every new observation
as much as possible.
So it's not as if I can
cleanly decomposed the two
contributions to the
result, but my sense
is that it's mostly adaptation.
And if you're doing some
other adaptive procedure,
especially if it's informed
by some prior knowledge
or topical area knowledge,
it's probably a good approach.
So I'll just tell you
about this one last thing.
OK?
We did an investigation about
another kind of uncertainty
in large systems.
So let's say that you're
developing the next tractor
or the next car, and
you think about applying
some robust design
to the system.
Now, for any reasonable
scale product,
there are literally
thousands of things
which you could potentially
apply a robust design
experiment to.
You can run one
on fuel injection.
You can run one on braking and
one on environmental controls
and one on electrical,
just keep going,
and you're not going
to do them all.
In fact, I would say less
than 5% of all opportunities
to do robustness improvement
work are actually executed.
And then the question I always
ask myself is I wonder if--
let's say, it's 5%--
I wonder if companies
are doing the right 5%.
I wonder if they know where
their biggest quality problems
are.
Now, we know for a fact that,
if you look at retrospectively
where there have been
big quality problems,
if I look at Ford Explorer
and the rollover and so on.
Right?
I know they didn't
do a robust design
study on tire inflation and
its delamination and rollover.
They didn't do it.
Now, why didn't they know
that that was the one
to do robust design on?
Well, they just didn't.
It was not so likely after all.
It wasn't happening
to other SUVs.
So I ask myself,
if you could run
a relatively expensive
robust design study on 5%,
let's say that's the case.
You have the budget for that.
What if you did something
a tenth as expensive
and did on 50% of the system?
So we would call this
idea streamlining.
We know how to take any robust
design experiment people are
proposing and to do
something a little bit loose
but to do it at a tenth of the
cost, and you'll get about 80%
of the same benefit.
The trade-off works like that.
It's a good old Pareto
80-20 sort of trade-off.
And we ask ourselves
how that trade-off
in doing relatively
many relatively less
perfect experiments compares
to doing a few very good ones.
And we ask ourselves
how this trade-off
is affected by the
likelihood of identifying
the one or two biggest quality
problems that you face.
Because that rollover
thing cost Ford a lot.
You would pay a lot of
money to avoid that one.
And so the big
conclusion of our study
is you would have to have
a pretty high probability
of knowing exactly where
your problems were in order
to do it the way
they do it now, which
is relatively small number
of expensive studies.
You'd have to know
like 95% certainty
where your biggest
quality problem is.
If you are at least
a little uncertain,
if you think you're only 70%
sure where your problems lie,
scale them all back by a factor
of 10, and do 10 times as many.
You'll be much better off.
That's my view,
and we didn't have
to make so many assumptions
to come to this conclusion.
People's uncertainty about
where their biggest issues lie
are bigger than they
think, and therefore, they
need to democratize
these kind of processes.
It's not that you
have to do them very,
very well in a few cases.
What you need to do is make
sure every engineer knows
how to do this kind of
thing, and that they're
doing it to almost everything.
At least almost everything
that, for example,
is not proven in
the field already.
You don't need to do
it on the alternator,
because you used that same
alternator on the last three
models, and it's fine.
But for anything
that's relatively new,
you need to be doing some of
this robustness refinement
work.
And even if you do
just a few experiments,
exposing your systems
to harsh conditions,
making changes,
making improvements
on the basis of
what that reveals,
that's the key thing, not so
much the finesse you apply.
Anyway, that's the
conclusion we came
to so far due to this research.
So our main
conclusions are that we
can show through empirical
work and through theorems
that this adaptive
procedure gives benefits.
You get a long way
toward your results
that are desired, especially
when interactions are not
so small.
And that you can cross
these adaptive experiments
with fractional
factorial designs
to use them for robustness, and
it seems to work pretty well.
And now, I think I'm
pretty much out of time.
Now, if you all have ideas
for your case studies,
I'm always interested in
head-to-head comparisons
of experimental
designs being done
in companies and the
adaptive procedures
that I'm talking about now.
So if you're interested in doing
such things for your projects,
I'm interested in
helping you to do that.
And you can see my
email there, in case
you want to take
me up on the offer.
OK?
All set?
All right.
Good day.
[APPLAUSE]
--Problems that we run into
quite often in microfabrication
is that the metrology of
the things that we've made
takes up quite a lot
of our time and budget.
It's quite easy to vary
parameters and make
many samples.
But choosing which
ones to measure
might be the biggest
challenge, and I
wonder whether you've
looked at situations, where
the acquisition of the
data lags, the doing
of the experiments, but
it's sort of concurrent,
but you can only measure
a certain portion
of the experiments you do.
Are there more complicated
situations like that
where there's a lag?
But it's not the case that
you do all the experiments,
and then you do all
the measurements.
PROFESSOR: It's an
interesting question.
So you're saying that
you can do an experiment.
There's a time lag.
Then you get an outcome.
And in some cases, it's actually
more complicated than that.
You get some
indication right away,
but the more preferred
measurement comes later.
So for example,
sometimes there's
a categorical variable that
becomes immediately obvious.
Either I heard
chatter, or I didn't.
And then later, I get
a nice measurement
of surface condition,
something like that.
Well, any of these
delays tend to weigh
in favor of the factorial design
as compared to the adaptive.
You just admit that right away.
But then I'll say
that sometimes,
even with categorical
variables, immediately available
perceptions, you can get a lot
of the benefit of adaptation
from that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK,
thank you very much.
Anybody else?
So we've arranged to have
an extra half hour today
where I can answer
questions about problem
sets and any questions
that you might
have in the run-up to the quiz.
So I think what we'll do is
just go straight into that.
If people want to run off at
this point, then that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to
[INAUDIBLE] the solution
of the problem sets [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
So there's a few
housekeeping things first.
Yeah, so problem sets, I will--
I'll put the solutions for
6 and 7 today at some point.
And I put the 2006 quiz, too,
and solutions on the website.
I'm still trying to track
down last year's quiz.
But hopefully that
will be out today.
And yes, for problem
set 8, I know
some people have been
sending me questions,
which I'm happy to continue
to answer by email.
I'll be around this afternoon
if you want to come and speak
to me in person.
And yes, last week, a few
people asked me for extensions.
That's fine.
If you need an extension,
you can have an extension.
I'm not super strict
about these things.
OK, so really, the floor is
open for you to ask me things.
And oh, yes grades for
6 and 7 will hopefully
be done within the
next day, as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So we have a question.
When you compare the Taguchi
method and a surface response,
this is for problem 4.
But you want to compare
the number of experiments
it takes for both methods.
Are you considering the
quadratic terms [INAUDIBLE]??
Or are you're not?
PROFESSOR: In question
4 on problems set 8,
we're talking about here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's right.
PROFESSOR: I think that
it's good to not include
the quadratic terms
in that question,
although you might
want to consider
what would happen if you did.
AUDIENCE: OK, so we're only
considering the linear terms
and interactions?
PROFESSOR: And
interactions, yeah.
I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: I think that's
the right way forward.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Only two
[INAUDIBLE] interactions
or three or four [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so with this, we're
not really interested
in quadratic factors.
Just look at the linear
factors in the interactions.
OK?
More questions?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one last question?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So
actually, [INAUDIBLE]
we are kind of confused
about question 2, problem 2.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, everyone's
confused about that.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So can you give
us a little [INAUDIBLE] we
are looking for in question 2?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I wrote this question in an
attempt to stretch everyone,
including myself.
So it's pretty subtle, I think.
But I would say the
right way to approach
this is to recast
that model in terms
of differences between the
variables and the mean input.
So if you have a set
of data, and those data
have a mean value for x1
and a mean value for x2,
so you might write it with
some new coefficients a--
x2 minus x-- sorry,
x1 bar, x2 bar.
And that will be for some values
of the a's that are functions
of the b's.
That will be equivalent.
And then, if it was just
the first two terms,
that would be
exactly the case that
was derived in Mayo & Spanos.
And then this term looks
very much like this term,
except it's for a
different variable.
So the standard error
of that coefficient,
you can get at by the same
way you got at this one.
And then if you
look at this term,
well, we have this
coefficient here.
Well, if you're trying to
evaluate the variance of y hat,
you've got a product
of two quantities.
Do you have an expression for
the variance of a11, which
you're going to get at
in a similar way to how
you get at the expressions
for these variances.
And you'll see the expression
for the standard error
is a function of--
is going to be a function
of x1 minus x1 bar.
And you know that
when you're finding
the invariance of some
constant times something
that you know the variance
of, you square that constant,
multiply it by the
variance of the thing
that the constant
was multiplied by.
AUDIENCE: Should it x1
star or x1 [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry, yes.
Yes, these are-- exactly.
There you go.
So this is-- yes,
you're trying to find
an expression for the
confidence interval
as a function of x1
star and x2 star.
But at a given at a given
combination of x1 star
and x2 star, this is the
thing that has variance.
And this, for a fixed
x1 star, is a constant.
So I don't want to
give too much away.
And I think this
is the right way.
There may be some subtleties
that have escaped me.
So if you can think
of any, let me know.
I think because there aren't any
interaction terms in our model,
I think that means
that covariances
don't need to concern you.
But if you think I'm wrong
on that, let me know.
OK?
AUDIENCE: So speaking of the
covariance, but x1 and x1
square, these two
are correlated.
So the covariance-- you have
to consider that one, right?
How could you ignore
that? x1 and x2,
they are not correlated--
x1 and x1 square.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, maybe I'm wrong.
Well, if you want to--
if you can work out how to
consider that, then tell me.
AUDIENCE: OK, but in
terms of the results, can
we just use an x--
the matrix as a general--
we don't need to break
down the matrix, right?
PROFESSOR: No, I
don't think so, no.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Anyone else?
Have we run out of coffee?
Yes, I expect so.
Let's see.
What are the things that
people are most puzzled
by in the material since quiz 1?
I mean, if someone
asked you to fit
a model to a
factorial experiment,
and you didn't have Minitab
what level of confidence would
people have in doing that?
I mean, is it really something
where you rely on the structure
that the software provides
to know how to calculate some
of the squares and so forth?
Because I can foresee
exam questions--
obviously not going
to have Minitab.
We're going to be dealing with
very small numbers of data,
and it's just going to
be a case of knowing what
to subtract from what, really.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] practice.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] with the
[INAUDIBLE],, you could do it.
But we won't
[INAUDIBLE] practice
doing it versus using JMP or
Minitab [INAUDIBLE] get used
to the data being [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think it would
be more time-consuming.
PROFESSOR: Fair point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I need to I need
to track it down, because
they didn't post it
on Stellar last year.
So I need to get
it up [INAUDIBLE]..
Yes?
Who's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question 4-- can you
explain more about the noise?
You mean that you cannot
[INAUDIBLE] during
an experiment?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Sure, yeah, this
question's a bit cryptic.
But really, all it's
asking you to do
is confirm your understanding
of the last question
on problem set 7.
You may recall
from that question
where you made that factor
z, that noise factor,
you were imagining that
you could control it
in that situation.
But then I think you will have
written an expression for y
in terms of the two
X's and the z factor
that showed that the sensitivity
of the output to variations
in z were a function
of x1 and x2.
So you could choose
a combination
of the control
parameters at x1 and x2
that would minimize
the sensitivity to z.
Now, really parts B
and C of problem 4
are just sort of checking
that that went in,
because if you can't control z,
but you know that if you're not
controlling it, it's probably
going to have a variance,
the input, the noise
input, is probably
going to have a variance that
doesn't change with time.
So you can see how much
of that noise propagates
through to the outputs
if the noise interacts
with the control input
variables-- in other words,
if there are these
product terms of z and x1.
You can't control z.
You can control x1.
Therefore, you can control
how much the noise propagates
through to the outputs.
And B and C aren't asking
you to write down very much.
It's just sort of checking that
the concept is there, really.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
OK, anyone else?
Dave?
AUDIENCE: Do you have an example
of a potential modeled problem
that might be of a
smaller data set that
might be a little easier
to go through some
of the calculations of fitting
a model to the experiment?
I know a lot of our [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit bigger,
and it may be useful to be
able to work something through.
PROFESSOR: That's
a very good idea.
Yes.
Yeah.
I'll try to come
up with something
that's sort of manageable
on a sheet of paper--
yes, very, very good thought.
We may be able to do
with some of the data
sets we used to look at ANOVA.
But yeah, fine.
AUDIENCE: I had some confusion
with problem [INAUDIBLE]
the lack of [INAUDIBLE]
I was having
some trouble with [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if
you could do [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
points, OK.
Fine, fine.
So that was on problem set 7.
You were at 12-1 or
something, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
No, that's a good point.
A lot of people had
difficulties with that.
So that I will look
at, as well, OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] problem
with something [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
Something [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: For example,
[INAUDIBLE] minus 1 [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
some examples.
[INAUDIBLE] data versus
[INAUDIBLE] so you don't have
enough information [INAUDIBLE]
I don't know why, but that's--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think there
is a mistake in Montgomery.
I need to track it down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] makes
sense [INAUDIBLE] look at that.
[INAUDIBLE] you don't
really need to add all data
and calculate all contrasts.
So there is some [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] example
you have [INAUDIBLE] data.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
On the Mayo &
Spanos, on the 8.1.3,
[INAUDIBLE] duration of
[INAUDIBLE] of the parameters.
It seems to me that
[INAUDIBLE] just jumping
and without [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're right.
AUDIENCE: 8.1.3 It's a general
form of the [INAUDIBLE]
regression [INAUDIBLE]
using the matrix [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
Well, sure, I can try to
find a complete derivation.
I think it's probably not
worth spending a lot of time
trying to understand that.
I would focus more
on the stuff that's
been in the problem sets.
But sure, I can
try to find that.
AUDIENCE: Because if you can
get a derivation of that,
any kind of regression
data just changes form.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there is no need
to do that kind of thing,
try to change the form of it.
[INAUDIBLE] just need to fit it.
PROFESSOR: Yes, I'm
sure you're right.
I'm sure you're right.